so we must unfortunately begin the show
today discussing some extremely
disturbing things that you don't want to
hear and i don't want to talk about but
then again the show almost always
consists of things you don't want to
hear and i don't want to talk about so
today it starts with the organization
called
the prostatia foundation if it already
sounds creepy and dystopian well you
don't know the half of it it also has
kind of a pharmaceutical ring to it
which may or may not be intentional i
don't know
prostatia has been around for a few
years it would seem
and it builds itself as a child
protection organization quote unquote
that might sound pretty good
child protection organization that's
that's a good thing
until you go to their website and you
spend
10 or 15 seconds
well you will quickly see that this
child protection organization concerns
itself with such causes as
kink awareness
and sex workers rights
and decriminalizing sexting for children
that's one of the things they want to do
prosthesia insists that there is a
sex-positive approach to uh childhood
sexting
the organization is also right now
planning and i'm this is quoting now
from the website planning quote research
into the use of fictional or fantasy
sexual outlets like sex dolls cartoons
and fictional stories
among people who have sexual attractions
to children
now as you may be clued into by now this
is not a child protection organization
quite the opposite but if you need to be
further convinced here's an introductory
video from their website watch this
prestasia foundation is a new child
protection organization dedicated to
promoting laws and policies that are
both effective and constitutional we're
a child protection organization and a
human rights organization we're actually
the first to bring mental health
professionals human rights activists sex
experts and internet platforms together
prostatia takes an evidence-based
approach based on preventing abuse
before it happens i think we're living
in a time when people are
frequently willing to
think that making policy based on belief
is a good idea
i'm not sure that's correct we don't shy
away from controversy
for example the idea that maybe we can
change the behavior of people with a
sexual interest in children or the fact
that the best place people to keep
minors out of sex work or the consensual
kink community are sex workers and
kinksters
and so my thing when i encounter minors
in kink is first of all that's great
that you're interested please come back
when you're 18. here are some books to
read we believe that it's possible to
protect children while upholding our
society's most important values such as
tolerance diversity and freedom
we're prestasia foundation
so i have that mental filing cabinet
open and i'm going through all of the
potential things i could say to describe
the people in that video
that won't get me banned from youtube
and i'm and i'm
there's nothing so we'll just we'll just
forge ahead yes our society's most
important value uh tolerance they say
now notice how she says that we have to
protect kids but we need to also make
sure that we're staying true to
society's most important values now me i
would say that society's greatest
priority is protecting kids
but that for them is an afterthought in
comparison to tolerance and what should
we be tolerant of well perstasia makes
it makes it abundantly clear through its
website and videos that we should be
tolerant of we should destigmatize what
it refers to as minor attracted persons
otherwise known as pedophiles
and they are not waging this war for
pedophilia normalization alone first of
all one of the men using the term
very loosely here
one of the men affiliated with this
organization is noah burlatsky and he's
a media figure
who has written for the atlantic the
washington post nbc i mean it's been all
over the place mainstream publications
and he is
works with this organization
that wants to
destigmatize pedophilia
because openly supporting pedophilia
will not preclude you from earning
bylines in major publications quite the
opposite it would seem
and there are others outside the
organization joining in this fight for
pedophilia acceptance including of
course college professors
in fact um just a few days ago uh or
last night um as libs of tiktok on
twitter brought to our attention
prestigious youtube channel they haven't
been banned from youtube of course i
mean they're still on youtube
they had an interview with a non-binary
professor from old dominion university
by the name of alan walker
alan walker has just written a book
available on amazon
hasn't been banned on amazon of course
arguing for tolerance of maps minor
attracted persons
here's alan talking about the book and
its arguments
um i use the term minor attracted person
or map in the title and throughout the
book for multiple reasons
first of all because i think it's
important to use terminology for groups
that members of that group want others
to use for them um and math advocacy
groups like before you act
have advocated for use of the term map
they've advocated for it primarily
because it's less stigmatizing than
other terms like pedophile
a lot of people when they hear the term
pedophile they automatically assume that
it means a sex offender
and that isn't true and it leads to a
lot of misconceptions about attractions
toward minors
i've definitely heard the idea that you
brought up though that the use of the
term minor attracted person suggests
that it's okay to be attracted to
children
but using a term that communicates who
someone is attracted to
doesn't indicate anything about the
morality of that attraction
you know maybe once the fbi is done
investigating soccer moms at school
board meetings they might want to have a
look at alan walker and the prestasia
foundation if it isn't too much trouble
that is
this is all quite horrifying and
nauseating and infuriating but we could
learn something important by listening
to the blood curdling freak in that
video now professor them says that we
should call pedophiles
minor attracted persons because it's
polite you know it's what the members of
that group have requested that we do
we should allow groups to define
themselves and we should use whatever
language they assigned to us
the last thing we'd ever want to do
professor them says is uh
is rather stigmatize them
now you see how so you see here how the
most the most hideous kinds of evil can
be dragged up from the bowels of hell
and sanitized and normalized
all in the name of politeness
and being respectful to communities
that's step one by the way
once once they start putting the label
community on a group of people
that's step one towards normalization so
now we're talking about the pedophilia
the pedophilia community
uh much like maybe we talk about the
serial killer community or the rapist
community
this is all under the assumption of
course that uh that groups and
individuals should be able to define
themselves and that we should never you
know we should never stigmatize anyone
is what we're being told of course the
people making this argument they don't
really believe it i'm sure that if a
white supremacist group asked politely
that they not be referred to as white
supremacists
nobody on professor them side of the
ball would care about respecting their
group identity
in fact the left will stigmatize people
who are not white supremacists by
calling them white supremacists even
though the people being labeled as such
don't want that label and also don't
warrant it warrant it
so there's no consistency here except in
the sense that the left only applies
this destigmatizing rule
to sexual groups
you know it turns out that they're
they're big fans of stigmatizing things
in general they they stigmatize all
manner of groups people ideas beliefs
value systems
they stigmatize a new thing every day
it's almost impossible to keep up
so the destigmatizing campaign is
reserved specially and exclusively
for sexual behavior and orientations and
groups
pedophiles are a
sexual group in a sense and it's always
been only a matter of time before the
campaign begins in earnest to push for
full mainstream acceptance of their
quote-unquote lifestyle choices
i mean the left is marched under the
banner of love is love right for years
and this is where that kind of slogan
leads
by design
now we'll be told that prestasia and
alan walker and their allies are fringe
and if that were true you know if they
were alone on the field fighting this
battle to normalize pedophilia and
sexualized kids you might not worry
about it so much it would be enough to
chalk them up to a small collection of
disgusting anomalous dirt bags and if we
lived in a sane society they'd all be
going to prison and that would be it
but the problem is that they're not
alone
just a few days ago we played for you
that news report out of fairfax county
virginia where adolescents and public
schools are being asked explicit
questions about their sexual lives their
sex lives
which isn't even a thing that should
exist
for kids
being asked that by their school for a
survey
yesterday we had the video of a young
boy in a dress and makeup paraded around
by his mother for applause applause what
she does indeed receive
we've talked about the dramatically
increased prevalence of lgbt
identification among kids trans
identification in particular has
skyrocketed in recent years
this this is the result this result has
been engineered precisely by sexualizing
kids from a young age
and as you know from this show the men
who invented the sexual revolution
revolution who invented modern sex ed
and the modern approach to these
subjects men like alfred kinsey wanted
to convince the public to see children
as sexual beings
that was their goal
kinsey even worked closely with
pedophiles in his research he did
experiments to study orgasms in babies
and the kinsey institute still exists
today
and is very well funded
so fringe
no
not at all
and beyond all that of course there's
pop music in hollywood and so on
altogether you see that the effort to
sexualize kids and thereby to normalize
the sexualization of kids
is
already mainstream
if prostatia and alan walker are unique
it's just that they have taken all of
this
to its inevitable conclusion well i hope
you enjoyed that clip for the matt wall
show if you did go ahead and hit that
subscribe button right down there so you
can stay up to date on all of our future
content